!
>> WELL DONE BY MILES BRIDGES,
AND THERE IS YOUR 19-YEAR-OLD
KIA NBA ROOKIE OF THE YEAR,
LaMELO BALL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, MAN, THANK YOU.
>> LaMELO, LET'S START HERE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW MY AGE,
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS GROWING UP,
MY FAVORITE PLAYER TO WATCH WAS
PETE MARAVICH.
WHEN I WATCH YOU PLAY, AND YOU
CAN WATCH ONLINE, PEOPLE HAVE
SEEN YOUR CLIPS THE WAY YOU PASS
THE BALL IS UNBELIEVABLE.
ONE OF MY FAVORITES IS THE
LENGTH OF THE COURT UNDERHAND
RIGHT ON TARGET.
SO WHAT WAS YOUR BIGGEST
INFLUENCE ABOUT THE WAY YOU PLAY
THE GAME?
>> SO, HONESTLY I WATCHED A LOT
OF PEOPLE, BUT PISTOL PETE, TOO.
I REMEMBER MY POPS SHOWING IN ME
A MOVIE FROM HIM.
I A LOT OF PEOPLE I WATCHED.
PENNY HARDAWAY, CURRY, MAGIC
JOHNSON.
PRETTY MUCH JUST LOOK AT
EVERYBODY TOGETHER, AND AT THE
END THROW A LITTLE BIT OF MY
STUFF ON IT.
>> LA MELLA, SHAQ.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU SHOULD
BE PROUD, YOUR FAMILY SHOULD BE
PROUD.
CONGRATULATIONS AND SHOULD GOD
CONTINUE TO YOU BLESS YOU.
>> A YES, SIR, THANK YOU, SHAQ.
GOOD LOOKS.
>> NUMBER ONE, CONGRATULATIONS.
WHAT WAS THE EASIEST AND THE
HARDEST THING ABOUT YOUR ROOKIE
YEAR?
>> THE EASIEST?
EASIEST IS JUST SHOWING UP,
BEING THERE.
I MEAN, IT'S BASKETBALL SO IT
PRETTY MUCH COME EASY TO ME.
THE HARDEST, I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO SAY WITHOUT PLAYING WITH
FANS, THE WHOLE CORONA THING,
WAKING UP FOR TESTING.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE HARDEST
THING I WOULD SAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
I'VE GOTTEN A CHANCE TO WATCH
YOU SINCE PROBABLY 15 ON THE AU
CIRCUIT.
YOU HAD SOME GOOD BATTLES WITH
YOUR BROTHERS.
YOU WERE THE YOUNGEST OF THEM
ALL.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY, YOU
TOOK THE UNCONVENTIONAL ROUTE TO
THE NBA.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK BACK ON IT, DO
YOU THINK THAT IT HELPED YOU?
OR NOT REALLY, OR IT MAYBE
HINDERED YOU, THAT
UNCONVENTIONAL ROUTE TO THE
LEAGUE?
>> I WOULD DEFINITELY SAY HELP
ME.
I'M ONE OF ONE, ALL THAT.
I FEEL LIKE IT JUST FITS ME, AND
IT'S WHO I AM, FOR REAL.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, YOU
STARTED THE YEAR COMING OFF THE
BENCH.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST START
THINKING, ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
MIGHT BE A POSSIBILITY HERE?
>> HONESTLY, WAY BEFORE THE
LEAGUE, HONESTLY.
WHEN I WAS PLAYING BASKETBALL
AND THEY WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
NBA STUFF, THAT'S WHEN I KNEW,
IF I'M A ROOKIE, THAT'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS I
COULD GET.
THEN PRETTY MUCH THE WHOLE BENCH
THING, I DIDN'T HAVE TOO MANY
PROBLEMS WITH THAT BECAUSE I
KNEW I WAS GOING TO GET IN AND
GET SOME TIME.
THE TIME I'M GOING GET, I'M
GOING TO MAKE SOMETHING OUT OF
IT.
HOPEFULLY THAT LEADS TO OTHER
OTHER THINGS AND HOPEFULLY IT
WORK OUT THE WAY IT SHOULD WORK.
>> aMELO BALL G